Because of a grippa trilmma. >> How do you not feel a grippa
trilmma? >> Oh man, that's really weird. What? Tell me
again. What does a grippa trillemma say? [laughter]
>> The optics. The optics. The optics, bro. The optics
are not good. >> But if they did, >> they don't.
>> Yeah, but if they did, >> they don't. I don't.
>> Yeah, but if they did, >> what what what person
enjoys? >> Like a pagan nation, let's say. >> It's
not good. It looks like she's like rattled. She's like losing
it. He's doing the face.
>> Okay. All right. So, how do we want to do this? Nick
Sh. Ah, not Nick Shirley stuff today. I had one thing. I only
had one thing that I wanted to cover from Twitter and it was
this post. How long is it? Now, I suspect this is not going to
be favorable toite. Okay. >> Your question and then I'm
going to have a meta conversation with you because I thought
that we were going to have a good faith conversation because
it's crazy. My favorite debate that I've ever had was with you
when we passed a bunch of rules in the hallway. >> The
one where we said, "Would you agree to being good faith?" And
you said, >> Yeah. The [laughter] >> So, it's funny.
>> So, you're just agreeing that you're being bad faith
for people who are unaware when I say bad faith. I just want
to be >> Forget the medical answer the question. You offiscated
not going to answer it. >> I will answer it afterward.
I can't. >> How do I I just got the weirdest feeling because
I know that I I know that I laugh like that, but I laugh like
that when I genuinely feel laughter.
I never laugh like that like just to go after somebody.
I laugh like that when I genuinely feel laughter when I'm like
cry when I'm laughing. That [__] that feels that
feels really up because I feel like I laugh like that and I I'm
I'm really put off. I I laugh like that, but I laugh like that
when I genuinely feel laughter and I don't know what she's genuinely
laughing at here. It's like a punch line to a bad face. I just
want to be >> forget the medical answer the question you
offiscated.
I'm not going to answer >> I will answer it afterwards.
I can't tell. I can't tell if you genuinely don't understand
a Grippa's trilmma maybe or if you're being bad faith. Those
are the only two. >> How am I being bad faith when you
pause an argument and I ask you about it? >> Relax, Andrew.
I said there's two options. You genuinely don't understand or
you're being bad faith. Right. There's a third option which is
maybe you don't understand especially for the purpose of this
conversation. >> No, no, no. Not for the purpose of this
conversation. Don't be like bad faith and presume. >> It
is bad faith to presume things that you don't actually believe.
Don't faith. Do not do not purport to me that you believe in
things that you don't believe. That is definitionally bad faith.
I mean, I've tried to internally critique you. You don't really
want it. Keep running away from it. >> and then being bad
faith and being like, "Oh, yeah. I actually don't think God exists.
It's all assumed." Hold on, Andrew. So, you're
>> you're being bad faith again. Oh, you're being bad faith,
Kylo, by saying I'm bad >> Good job. >> I just g
>> I I genuinely,
how do I put this?
I have a hard time when people use stuff that's got weird names
and very low utility.
Like, would it just be easier for you to explain what you're
talking
than actually use this word that then you'll have to explain
anyway,
right? You need to know that somebody has read the same thing
you have
before you use
Who watches this? Who is it for? I have no idea. I honestly I
have no idea who watches whatever. I I would watch an Andrew
Wilson noticed debate. I'm not even saying that actually. I as
much as other people may not like this, I would want to watch
a debate between them on a lot of topics because I think they're
both entertaining performative debaters and I think it would
be a show. So, I think it would be very fun. I have no interest
in watching an 8 and 1 half hour debate, which is what this was.
They talked for 8 and 1/2 hours.
What in the is the point?
How in the world do you talk for 8 and 1/2 hours to another person
and like have any meaningful resolution to anything? It's like
there's no scope. There's nothing.
I don't I don't get it. Why would people fly out for this? Also,
it doesn't make sense to me. Anyway, it's whatever.
literally.
But
again, the this Agria's trillemma thing. So I look it up. Agria's
trillemma. Agria's trilmma in the meaning of life. Essentially
the trilmma sets out to ask is it possible to prove any truth?
Essentially according to the argument, no. It is impossible to
prove the prove the validity of any of an argument. Ironic no.
Um broke it out. The trilmma states no argument is provable because
the why can never be answered because of the following flaws.
Circular reasoning. A logical fallacy in which the reasoner begins
with what they are trying to end with. A is true because B is
true. B is true because A is true. Example, the HR director told
us lying is to the boss is bad. Why is lying to the boss bad?
Because the HR director told us so. So lying is bad. Infinite
regress.
These sorry those who have children can likely relate to this
next example or those who have an employee who is never satisfied
with your response. A child asks a question. The parent gives
a response. The child asks why. The parent answers. The child
asks why. The parent answers. This continues forever.
The answer in the loop only exists because of the previous answer
and there is no answer that y cannot to that. There is no answer
that y cannot be a response to. I guess okay aximatic statements.
This is a statement that is taken to be true to serve as a starting
point for further reasoning and arguments. It is a statement
that doesn't require proof. It is self-explanatory. You have
likely heard conversations where someone says maybe you. It's
common sense. Common sense demands that the person is aware and
familiar with certain things in the environment. Another is anything
to do with God or religion. Maybe the math says this or the science
says this. When we hear these statements, we are to assume that
what follows or preceded is true based on pre-existing knowledge
that doesn't require any other proof.
So basically, you can't prove an argument without one of these
three things happening.
I don't know what I don't know what
So, this is probably in response to Andrew doing like a like
a Y consistently, I would imagine,
or something. Also,
is this actually a trillemma? Why is it called a trilmma?
A trilmma is a very specific thing. A trillemma is not just three
different things. A trillemma is something where the three like
legs
actually act on each other,
right?
A dilemma is when you're comparing two things. A triillemma is
when three things that like a dilemma is you measure trade-offs
and you try to choose between two things, right?
A trillemma is the the three trade-offs like all work against
each other. That's the purpose of a trillemma.
Um difficult is a difficult choice from three options each of
which is or appears unacceptable or unfavorable. There are two
logically equivalent ways in which to express a trilmma. Could
be expressed as a choice between three among three unfavorable
options. One of which must should be chosen or as a choice among
three favorable options.
of only two of which are possible at the same time. Yes. So when
you move any direction in the triangle, you get further away
from one of the solutions. As you move in a direction on the
triangle, you get further away from one of the solutions as in
these solutions work against each other. But it sounds like there's
two ways it could be expressed. And so I'm talking about the
second one where like you basically get to pick optimizing for
two. Yeah. Anyway, so I've always I've always heard it this way
where basically um
it's like an optimization problem. I like I like hearing about
things like this that are an optimization problem to be honest.
Here we go. The the Xjac trillemma.
The impossibility of demonstrating loyalty to the communist regime
while also being honest and intelligent. That basically like
you could be Yes. Yes. Yes. That like as you become more loyal
to the communist regime and more intelligent, you needless you
you by necessity become less honest.
Right.
This is my idea of a
But apparently there's two versions. So unlucky. Anyway, so agria's
trilmma or something. And I just I this whole point was and I
feel like you have to understand it to know whether or not it
was required. I feel like the only reason you introduce something
like a grippa trillemma
is because it makes you sound smart. So like I don't know. I
now I need to go to the whole whatever debate and I actually
have to break this down. I'm sorry. It's like my own autism.
Okay, it's my own autism. But now I have to go to the whatever
podcast and actually watch this aerodite whatever thing and figure
out where agria's trilmma came in cuz now I need to know contention
over questioning and agria's trilmma >> to want to interrogate
>> I haven't said you can interrogate my position I said
can you wait for a second so I can ask you some questions because
in the case I was interrogating your worldview with the first
prompt I also allowed you to interrogate my worldview in return
>> let's let me do the interrogation
you can do your second >> okay so do you think that we
should >> No no I said let me do my interrogation first.
You can do your second. >> I'm saying I would like a back
and >> But all that does is derail from the questions I
have. >> Uh derails from the dunk that you're trying to
lead me into. I understand that it does that. Well, because what
you're trying to do is to get to some foundational thing of being
like, see, it's born on nothing. It's like, okay, Andrew, that's
what's bad faith. >> Do you want to try not allowing your
>> Everyone knows that this is what's happening. Wait,
you're So you're saying that your position when it's interrog?
I hoped cuz I don't want this to literally be the way these things
work. I personally hoped that she wasn't. You know what? I actually
have to go back. I have to go back. I have to go back and we
have to do the previous question. Whatever the previous segment
was that for like 100 years a nation >> because I assume
what happened here is basically one of these I think we're gonna
go to the infinite regress thing. I think that's what we're going
to do. And so she basically had this problem with infinite regress.
And instead of saying, you understand that you could just keep
asking me why forever and and increasingly like demand a level
of like certainty here and that like it's not going to actually
go anywhere. Like there is this fallacy standing alone. I hope
this doesn't happen where Andrew just keeps asking why or keeps
asking increasingly like narrowing questions, never ever giving
her a chance or like operating in good faith in a way where he
stops and says, "Okay, I didn't see the grabber coming."
I don't know, man. I don't know why the grabber was there to
grab water, hand out water to people. But do you understand how
it would really frustrate me if she talked about a grippa's trillemma
here and that it was essentially
it was essentially like one part of it and made the reference
to a grippa trillemma totally worthless?
I hope not. I hope not. If if if you needed all parts of the
trillemma to talk about it,
then I'm okay. If you only had one part of this trillemma, then
you were talking about one thing and you didn't need to talk
about Agria's trilmma and you made it actually need you needlessly
obiscated your point by referencing a grippa trillemma.
>> So I hope that didn't happen. Figuring truth in the
trilmma. Finding truth in the trillemma sacrificing children
nationwide census. That's where we are. >> Every third
baby >> we have to watch >> that comes up in the
nation. It's like overpop populated. I don't have >> China
as an example. >> How's that not working? Oh, it seems
like it was really, really bad for China. It seems like it was
really bad for the fact that people don't like seeing dead babies
cured everywhere. Uh, it seems like it crushed their >> As
long as the nation though consents to >> Well, it's not
just about what the nation consents to. Like, >> yes. You
said, and your exact words, I wrote them down. They should rule
via consent because I like consent cuz I like democracy.
>> Yeah. So, when I say rule by consent, that doesn't mean
that states craftmen aren't imposing laws that are reasonable
and work, right? The law is about like what makes a state work.
>> Yeah. But there's no contradiction in how the state
would not work if they killed every third child. >> How
would that state logistically work? I feel like that state >> it
would work fine. They used to do it all the time. They used to
sacrifice children all the time inside of Rome, inside of many
states. Sure. >> And it worked just fine. >> Well,
not really. Like I would argue >> Well, I would argue a
lot of the Where are Where are those nation states?
>> They lasted a lot longer than America. Some of them
>> Where are they? Well, are you saying that? So that's
a facious argument. You saying because this didn't continue in
perpetuity, that means it didn't work that I could just say,
well, don't you agree that America as it exists right now is
not going to exist in perpetuity. Therefore, it doesn't work
>> probably because there theoretically and hopefully there'll
be better systems that emerge. >> Okay. So then it doesn't
work. >> Uh by and large, no. Not by what I mean. >> What?
Okay. So I just want to make sure. >> So Rome didn't fall,
right? just because of one thing. But when we look at, for example,
a nation that killed every third baby. >> Can you grab
me another beer while you're up? >> This probably wouldn't
work for a number of reasons. Number one, citizens don't like
their babies.
>> But if they did, >> they don't. >> Yeah.
But if they did, >> they don't. I don't. >> Yeah.
But if they did, >> what what what person enjoys killing
their babies? >> Like a pagan nation, let's say, >> I
I would basically argue that they don't enjoy their babies either.
Usually like even when you look at pagan nations where babies
are killed, right? often times when you can find evidence for
it. The mother of that child for example or the father of that
child are completely opposed to it. It's usually forced upon
them, right? They don't enjoy it necessarily and usually the
child sacrifice was occurring. >> But if there's consensus,
what grounds would you oppose the consensus? >> What makes
the state work best for most of the people? >> Yeah. And
most people have now given >> Wait, there's no the child
sacrifice thing. This doesn't work
cuz this this doesn't work because like they they perceive the
utility is higher for the child sacrifice.
That's the whole point is they it's they don't they don't say,
"Well, we actually just love babies." They say, "We kill babies
because the harvest comes in good and we're all going to die
unless we kill this baby." You're basically arguing like they
see a massive positive utility in doing the sacrifice.
Like there there's no way there there's no way without um
Yeah. They they literally just see it as good, right? They have
to do it. >> New consensus that this is working best for
us. >> No, no, no, no, no. Like I don't know what Andrew
is saying. It's it shouldn't be about them liking it. It's not
about liking babies or wanting to kill babies. Like I think maybe
family members will kill babies that look like that like if they're
sickly, they look like they're not going to survive. They're
going to be a drain on you. That would happen. But I'm saying
if actual child sacrifice that was happening in places where
they assumed that it was netting them a positive gain. So you
would have consensus. You would have consensus and it wouldn't
make sense, but you would have consensus against your thing.
It's probably a good example of Andrew's thing where like based
on false belief, you could get consensus behind things that are
almost as certainly like objectively monstrous, like nearly objectively
monstrous. Not actually, but nearly.
You could easily do this, right?
They you can't give consensus that this is working for us. We
actually have to look at like material like outcomes, right?
So for example, how we know that America's law system works pretty
well, although there are problems, is the fact that our military
is the strongest, we have the most amount of scientific output,
which is awesome, right? That we are the number one currency
in
I don't think I don't think Nazi Germany's like um legal system
worked all that well and they had massive scientific output,
massive technological
I this is a horrible argument
I think I >> the largest like think so we know okay the
system that we centrally kind of erected around for the most
part works pretty well it's a pretty competitive
>> okay but that's post hawk does do you agree with me
that it takes time for you to gather data on a system which is
>> okay great so we've seen >> you mock the Germans
in production and you managed to mock them in science in the
very end but you mocked the Germans in production
So yes, but they were going
because you weren't in wartime. America wasn't in wartime. That's
why they were able to do stuff.
I think like the Nazi regime just had Yeah, they were scientifically
like pretty
forward thinking and far ahead of people. I just I and I don't
think they had were very concerned about law and or giving people
like a free trial or liberal values was my point. Anyway, >> for
years so for 5 years we have a consensus that we kill every third
baby and the people go along with it and they adore it. They
think it's great. We don't have the data to show them how wrongheaded
they are yet. >> I don't think that would emerge. >> So,
okay. But it has emerged. I >> I think it's but it has
no. Yes, it definitely has. There's definitely been many nations
where they
>> Okay, I What if it's just that like
coincidentally coincidentally you have this happen?
Just say coincidentally this happens. >> You happen to
sacrifice like a bunch of kids or something, right? >> You
sacrifice a bunch of kids and your economy improves massively
and coincidentally this happens. The whole point Andrew is making
is that like
>> just because a positive util exists for something doesn't
mean it's good.
Like I think er I think that's broadly where he's going to be
going, but I haven't been watching enough. Why do I have to I
should be less talking about this. I think that's the argument
he's been going with is just because society thinks there's a
positive benefit to something doesn't mean morality should be
based on that. And that's what liberalism is is the morality
of the masses collected and and enforced on other people. Right.
>> Yeah. Other children including China. So I don't know
what you're talking about. >> But it didn't work. In fact,
one of the >> Yeah. It you that's post hawk. That's you
post hawking. It didn't work after the fact. We're talking about
in the >> that's how you develop >> state. In the
fact though >> in when it's happening
>> what are you appealing to to oppose it? >> Me
personally.
>> Oh, me personally? Well, I'm a defined command theorist.
I would say that murdering babies is wrong. >> Okay, gotcha.
>> So, the consensus would be wrong >> against my
moral,
>> dude. So, so Arerite just said divine command theory.
I don't know why she would do that because now she immediately
has to go into the bifurcated morality where she doesn't apply
her morality onto anybody else. Therefore, it's not morality
cuz she she says I'm a divine command theorist. So, I'm going
to say this and Andrew is not asking what are you saying for
just yourself. She's not asking he's not asking you for the moral
version of the Hassan [__] Well, for me personally,
I wouldn't do that, but I'm not going to criticize other people.
He's not asking for that. He's asking for what's your thing
or maybe I'm reading too much into this again. We'll >> Okay.
So, you hold so you hold a form of >> because otherwise
Yeah, Andrew knows. Andrew is immediately going to her thing.
Okay. Cuz Andrew should just argue as if she's saying what she's
going to enforce on other people and then he's like, "Great,
you're a Christian nationalist. Let's go hand in hand, brother.
Christian nationalism."
>> Uh,
no. This is would be relativism.
Well, d Well, not really. >> It's not relativism. It's
relativistic is probably the better. >> Relativistic perhaps,
but it's this sounds like dual ethics. >> No, it's just
relative relativistic. >> Well, why is consensus
good? >> It's not ontologically good. >> Okay, good.
So, >> I think it makes the most I think for the most part
Well, I can answer you. >> All right, >> breathe.
You're going to be okay. So, for the most part, I think that
for
>> we're being good faith >> consensus is good because
it's worked. I think it's worked in so far as America mostly
has a democratic consensus type system which has worked pretty
damn well. I think the world outside is pretty good. There are
a lot of problems that people will point to, but I think America
overall is a pretty good nation. I think most western liberal
democracies are better than we've ever developed any at any time
in history. So the grounds that you would oppose
I truly believe this is why I say you should just accept the
fluke hypothetical because I truly believe
capitalism or some form of like capital markets is essential
but the liberal democracy I don't believe is essential.
I think that but for like a quirk of history, Germany being overtly
anti-semitic, sending like several very prominent scientists
to the US so they could catch up with all of their research very
quickly,
I do think there's a chance that like a fascist regime takes
over the planet or a communist regime takes over the planet.
Um, probably America does quite well, but I I do think there's
like some some quirks of history or let's say just um like kings
actually come over to America and take America or something,
right? I think America is really more key to being a productive
industrial nation, like the land of America, than almost anything
else. Capital markets, I said I believe I said capital markets.
Um, so I just I think I think whoever had gotten to America and
basically had the Renaissance like the open water navigation
level of science, I think whatever country that was, whatever
regime that was, I think they could have easily focused on this
and taken it and developed and outstripped almost everything
eventually. I I guess there's some critical mass you have to
reach in population before you can even become any kind of threat.
So maybe that maybe that develops slowly.
But in any case, I do think the the productive output of America,
the
the what would you say the geographic advantages of America are
really difficult to overcome. And if a fascist nation had taken
root in America, I do think especially around the time of let's
say like
let's say when the red scare is happening, a fascist nation kind
of takes root in in you know I guess opposition to communism
or something. I don't know. I just think I think there's a lot
of scary that could have happened. Okay. I don't think liberal
democracy is quite as built in at the the easiest best way to
do things as like people say. I actually don't. Um I think it's
the best system to live in for the average person. I do not think
it's necessarily the most efficient or most effective system
that will always win over everything else just because it balances
um incentives well. I think that is I think that is a big thing.
I don't think it's all of it. >> A consensus of every third
baby would be Christian ethics, right? Well, it would probably
be multiple things. Yeah. That I would appeal to. Like I would
use multiple evidences for it.
>> the reason I personally wouldn't kill babies is because
I think it's wrong to murder babies. >> Okay. Gotcha. >> Do
you think it's wrong? >> But if there was a consensus,
>> Well, yeah, of course. But if there was a consensus,
you said that's the thing that we should run things by is by
>> That might become state law. But I'm saying to you,
a I think that would fall out of state law very quickly. And
I would probably be a person who would advocate strongly against
that state law cuz not all state laws are moral >> based
on your morality >> to some degree, but I wouldn't be imposing
my morality. >> What if the consensus is that you're not
allowed to oppose the consensus?
>> Like an authoritarian regime? >> Well, no, that
wouldn't be authoritarian. That would be democratic.
>> Uh, how so? >> Because you can democratically
vote in laws which are oppressive.
>> Sorry. So I I feel like you're just making something
into democracy that doesn't exist. Could you explain it >> Yeah.
If everybody votes tomorrow in a >> Andrew said that really
he should have just said, "What if you're what if you're like
working against that's totally ineffective?
You're just going to be okay with babies getting killed?" >> Kyla
can never say another word or else I don't know she gets beat
to death with a rock. >> I would have due process. >> Okay.
Well, the thing is >> and I could argue free speech that
violates my amendment. >> Hang on. You didn't say due process.
You said consensus is how we should rule. >> Consensus
is typically how we select for like electoral people. And then
electoral people are hopefully although not always supposed to
be educated in such a way that they can make state craft policies
that brings about most good for citizens because I don't think
state craft is in and of itself moral. >> Okay. So we're
not actually appealing to consensus for how we should run things
then. Well, to some degree because the stakeholder is the voter.
So to some degree, you have to appeal to what stakeholders believe.
>> So what's preventing what's preventing voters in a liberal
democracy from voting in laws which go against your >> Well,
why why is she I Okay, now I'm like a little more up to this.
Why is she not just granting this part?
Yeah, that is how it works. Yeah, you could easily live in a
democracy where they vote in things that you think are totally
immoral. Literally everybody literally everybody understands
this. That's the whole abortion thing. You just have to grant
this. Why is she fighting? Stop fighting. Just give this one
away. >> Well, I would basically I would argue that God
puts like a sense of conscious within each of us. And I don't
think that almost anyone actually emerges in such a way that
they say it's good to kill babies. I think for example, pagan
institutions did erect.
Dude, I'm sorry, but like the only reason you don't think you're
babies right now is that you don't think of like the like zygote
is a life.
And I I would agree with her. I don't think it's necessarily
a life, but it's like that's the only reason you're not already
agreeing you killed babies.
She used God against Andrew. No, she didn't. She's saying something
totally.
She She is doing the duelist thing. Why is she Don't come back
and do this, MAN. COME ON, MAN. >> Very historic. >> She's
trying She's literally trying to say, "Well, on a personal basis,
you have to agree with my personal morality and then but I I'm
not going to ever try to take my personal morality and put it
out into the world. I would oppose based on like something else
that doesn't exist. It's not the consensus and it's not my personal
morality." Okay. If you're if you disagree with the consensus
and you don't want to push your personal morality onto people,
how do you actually advocate? How do you go out and say that
you want to oppose this policy?
You're literally saying you think the consensus thing is good.
Like there is there seems to be some gap here. No, none of them
use God even less. You literally don't understand what you're
talking about. You're >> and you will notice >> Andrew
literally doesn't ever argue God makes him correct. Andrew has
never argued that a single time.
How do you watch this channel and you don't pay attention to
anything this guy's ever said? It's insane. >> They don't
exist anymore because they don't work very well and people don't
like them. And I also would argue that they were moral at the
time, right? And so in the case of state craft, we would use
consensus to vote in elected representatives and these elected
representatives would impose laws. But if we don't agree with
those laws, then we can oust that person. We have federal >> That's
not my question. My question >> go find me the go find
me the clip, right? Go find me the clip even less where Andrew
Wilson says, "You're wrong because God tells me to do this."
As if it's in any case where it's like not a thought experiment
of some kind. You're wrong because God said no.
Go find me the argument where he makes that argument. The whole
reason, the whole thing he's built his entire debate empire is
because he always says, "I'm never going to use divine command
to argue you're wrong." But it is what I personally believe.
And if you want to attack me for that, at at worst, divine command
is my is my thing. And at worst, it's my preference. So you think,
you argue based on your preference, right? That's what liberalism
is. I'm arguing based on my preference. I'll never ever invoke
divine command to tell you that you're wrong, but it is what
I believe. He's arguing that he believes it. He's saying that
he's never going to invoke it to say somebody's wrong because
he doesn't believe that that wins debates. Like if they don't
believe in divine command, then you can't change their mind.
So he argues based on like whatever logical things he could do
or whatever debate he does, but he doesn't do the thing where
he says you're wrong because God said you're wrong.
question is, >> yes, he uses it to justify his beliefs,
but he's not debating with it. >> What actually prevents
inside of a liberal society from people utilizing consensus in
order to pass?
>> Yeah. But but nobody really dis disputes that you have
no grounding. That's the whole point of arguing the liberal worldview
is you you don't say there's something grounded because for something
grounded to exist, you have to be intolerant of certain ideas,
right? There isn't really a grounding. You basically are arguing
to various levels of consensus. It's the whole point of utilitarianism.
It's the whole point of a whole bunch of philosophical schools
of thought. >> Laws which are immoral
>> from your view.
>> Immoral from my view. >> He says he says but hold
on when he makes that argument even less. The only reason he
ever makes that argument is to just say we're both operating
on preference. Don't worry about what my preference is. We're
both operating off of preference.
Our systems are the same. And I don't think that's wrong. >> Nothing.
But I don't think that every Wait, I don't think that all of
>> Hold on. I need to back it up about 10 >> Inside
of a liberal society from people utilizing consensus in order
to pass laws which are immoral
>> from your view.
>> Immoral from my view? >> Nothing. But I don't
think that every Wait, I don't think that all of my moral system
should be rule of law. >> I understand. >> Do you
think that >> all I'm doing is is making sure that I get
the that I get it right. >> Can I ask you a question? >> Yes.
Do you think that >> Before you do, I'm going to interrogate
the position, then you can interrogate
>> I would just like to have some back and >> That's
the fair way to do it. But the problem is is you just divert.
>> Wait, no. That's the the first
>> So now here's the problem. I know you guys can't tell.
I actually want to take Aerodite's side in this argument.
>> She represents something far closer to my beliefs than
what Andrew thinks. I actually want to take Aerodite side in
this argument.
But now I've watched I've gone back and watched. I think he's
trying to hint at something and she's trying to get away from
something she's been criticized for before and he's asking questions
that hint directly at that criticism. This dual moral position
doesn't really make sense because you're literally like deferring
to people who if the consensus ever works against your personal
beliefs, you've lost you've seated any ground to like argue that
you should have your beliefs like represented. You've basically
totally seated ground
on this, right? like it doesn't
you're doing this thing like morality has to basically I think
be universal. You have to say this is what's moral, right?
So I I think he's literally hinting at something that I know
she has been criticized for in the past and he's having a hard
time like pinning it down precisely. Not having a hard time.
He's like trying to
he's trying to get her to admit it and she's saying no no no.
And I think there's like a hole there, right? there's a hole
there where she's saying I don't want to put my morality on anyone
else and he says so you want to you want to basically defer to
consensus and she says no then the what are we doing what's happening
man >> conversation we had the first like >> I don't
care about the meta just let me finish the interrogation because
you're doing some you're doing like
I want this how's it bad faith to want to >> I haven't
I haven't said you can interrogate my position I said can you
wait for a second so I can ask you some questions because in
the I was interrogating your world view with the first prompt.
I also allowed you to interrogate my world view in return. >> Let's
let me do the interrogation first and then you can do yours second.
>> Okay. So, do you think that we should >> No, no.
I said let me do my interrogation first, you can do your >> I'm
saying I would like a back and >> But all that does is
derail from the questions I have. >> Uh derails from the
dunk that you're trying to lead me into. I understand that it
does that. Well, because what you're trying to do is to get to
some foundational thing of being like, see, it's born on nothing.
It's like, okay, >> that's what's bad faith. >> Do
you want to just try >> not allowing your position?
>> Do you want to just So
now I I have my answer that I I think this is invoked totally
worthlessly
that I I don't understand the purpose of this being invoked.
I now I want to hear why she's invoking it.
Now I actually do. I And listen, I I myself was good faith. I
did not just immediately say she's totally for doing that. There's
no reason to do that. I went back and listened to try to see
what she why she was invoking it. And now
I can't think of why she would invoke this, why she would need
all three legs of this and need to use it by name.
In fact, I'm not even sure.
I'm actually I think it's going to be the infinite regress thing,
not the aimatic statement
But I we'll see. We'll see. Everyone knows that this is what's
happening. >> Wait, you're So you're saying that your position
when it's interrogated its foundation is going to be incoherent?
>> I would say every single foundation of any worldview,
normative or meta ethics is unjustifiable. Yes. This is what
axioms are. >> Oh, really? >> They all fail a Gria's
trilm. Yes. >> Because because of a grippa trilm. >> How
do you not fail a grippa trilmma? >> Oh man, that's really
weird. What? Tell me again. What does a grippa trillemma
>> dude? Jeez. Uh, I don't know. I feel like I now I can't
tell. Does he know what it is or does he not know what it is?
Because I do think
I do think here that
he's trying to basically point out like you just use a big word.
What? What? Oh my god. Tell me what does that big word mean?
And he might actually know what it means and he's going to try
to correct her on the answer. I think this is probably not smart
for him because Kyla usually when she does invoke these things
when when she does go with these big words she can explain them
right it's not like she's invoking them she invokes them I think
way too fast
yeah
but I don't think that I don't think she fails to understand
them she just I I think she wants to pull them up >> it's
dogmatism all all justification systems fail at a foundational
level because they will fail in one of three ways or all of three
ways. Dogmatism, infinite regression, and circular >> Is
that position justified?
>> Dogmatism, axiomatic statements, I
>> Okay. So, anyway, back to this. >> Wait. So, you
run away from [laughter] a
>> Okay. But you know what? >> I ran I ran away from
it.
>> So, I'm pretty sure Andrew's whole purpose with this
her response, why don't you tell me what it is? No, no, no, no,
no, no, no. I think Andrew is basically saying that if your argument
is everything fails at Grio's trillemma
then you argue the points like you're you're literally debating
right that's the whole point of debate is you do this back and
forth asking questions if your argument is just a grippa's trillemma
then that applies to your argument for a grippa's trillemma or
something I think that's what he's trying to say
>> you just said that a grippa's trillemma is not a justified
position >> well what do you mean by justified >> well
whatever you mean by it A grippa's >> Well, it's a it's
an internal critique of justification systems. A grippa what
do you mean is a grippa's trillemma unjustified? How do you solve
a gria? >> Well, it's self-refuting. This has been known
for a thousand years. I don't know if you know this or not. It's
a self-refuting. A grippa trillemma is self-refuting. If >> so,
how do you not engage in dogmatism? >> If all things are
axiomatic, right? >> the reduction to aimatic. Are we making
a truth claim? >> Uh, you are making a truth claim. >> Okay.
And is that truth claim justified?
>> Yeah. Yeah, cuz you assume. Wait, are you not making
a truth claim? >> It doesn't matter. >> Of course
it does. Are you not making truth claims? >> Wait a second.
>> Does your moral system not utilize truth >> Did
you posit an argument to me? >> Which was a Grippa trailemma?
>> And was that argument justified? >> Uh, no. >> No.
More than any Wait, is your arguments justified?
>> Yeah. So I Oh, no. She didn't think about this.
I This is at Unless I'm missing something. This seems like a
pretty
the now I maybe there's some reason agria's trillemma doesn't
apply to a grippa's trillemma specifically but is this not the
the same thing like it's basically saying that you can't it's
saying that basically all arguments break down to one of these
three things that things aren't generally provable like eventually
you're going to have to get into
like how do you trust your eyes or something how do you trust
your senses or perceiving the world like how do you perceive
the world like there's something about how do you even have knowledge
theory of mind you probably go all the way to these with anything.
You could do the infinite regress all the way down, right? And
then eventually you get to some axiom. Yeah. Yeah. It's it's
basically saying that like essentially you don't have perfect
understanding of the world. So you actually can't prove anything.
Yes.
Right. You basically don't know. You don't have perfect knowledge
of the universe. So you can't prove anything. I think that's
essentially what this is
And so I'm guessing that if you're going to say you don't get
to make this claim because of a grippa trillemma, then you can
also say, well, a grippa uno reverse agrip's trilmma. Okay. I
I think that's what they're saying. That what does that have
to do with you? >> I'm internally critiquing you this.
>> You can internally critique me with your >> How
are you not Yeah. So I said, "How do you not fail a Gria's trillemma?"
And you said, "A Grippa's trilmma doesn't matter." That's not
how you solve a matter. You said it's unjustified. Well, it's
self-refuting.
>> How is it self-refuting?
>> you would have to understand that it's self-refuting,
right? >> If you claim that there you're you're making
a truth claim that's unjustified, then you're not making a truth
claim.
>> True, you are. You're just assuming
I guess engages in dogmatism. It's not
>> uh you need to go to a meta level here and say any any
any
justification you use for using a grippus trillemma I can use
for my truth claim too. It will always be mirrored. It'll always
be perfect or something, right? There would be some I I assume
there's some way you can get out of this, right? Like there's
some I I it feels like one of these like infinite regress literally
just has to be that you could use infinite regress to consistently
ask questions and then eventually you get down to like how do
you know that you don't live in a simulation where where the
like known building blocks of the universe can't be changed overnight?
Is that not the whole point of the argument is it's like you
can literally just go through and keep asking questions in any
argument
because I'm assuming it eventually comes down to something about
being good faith in debates,
right?
Like that you need to you need to allow people to you need to
accept some axiomatic statements. You need to stop just asking
like meaningless questions at some point,
right? I I think
but it's fine. We'll keep watching. >> It's defined. >> Yeah.
So a grip is >> I don't have a background in philosophy.
So I've got a sound for this. I am totally indulging in this.
Okay.
But I I do believe that's what's being >> Trilmma I suppose
engages in dogmatism itself. But how is it self-refuting? >> You
just explained it. >> Every single system is self-refuting
them by this. >> Is that a truth claim? >> Okay.
And does that fail because of agria's trilmma? So should I take
anything you say seriously? Because >> give me give me
a single truth. >> I don't have to make your argument.
>> Going to run from this one again. Watch. Give me a single
truth claim that doesn't fail a Gria's trilmma. Go. >> Okay,
first of all, back up. Whose argument is this? >> Give
me a single truth claim that doesn't fail a
I do think Andrew's kind of got her
>> I don't know why I think she normally has better arguments
than I
I maybe I'm just missing something. I feel like they must have
done this as a
Like they must have argued this in a VC or something and this
must have done well. I'm just trying to think of like what am
I missing? I got to be missing something. They wouldn't be doing
this argument right now if if I was just totally not missing
something.
>> I knew you were going to weasel on this one. I'm just
going to stay here. >> Okay, stay here. Whose argument
is it >> right now? Both of us. We're both
Wait a >> Are we both having a conversation? >> I
didn't argue that a Grippa triilma is true. You did. I said it's
true in like an assumed way in the way that all things are assumed
in >> so is it true or not? >> So it's it's true
in an axiomatic way. It's like true in an axiomatic way I
dude it can't be that simple. It can't it cannot be that simple.
That would be very goofy >> I suppose. Like yeah true in
the way that we mean true for everything else that's true. >> What
does that mean? >> Well give me an example. >> Yeah
it's not my argument. You don't get to interrogate me for your
argument. No, no. I'm asking you for a counterfactual to prove
it. >> He's asking you to prove your argument. My argument
is nothing is nothing is this thing you're saying. >> Can
you provide me a counter? >> So nothing's true. >> I
didn't say nothing's true. I said truths are truths are assumed
>> Truths are assumed. Tautology. >> Do you know?
Yeah. No. Truths are assumed throughies. >> Truths are
tautologies
>> oftentimes at a foundational level. >> Often or
are
>> So is a Gria's trilmma a truth tautology? It's not an
axiom. It's [clears throat] a philosophical system. And it's
a philosophical.
>> But you just said you it's assumed true. You just said
it's assumed true. And
did I miss this? That she said they are truths are tautologies.
And and the same way and these are it's true. The same way all
truths are true. Am I my brain is breaking, but I think she basically
just contradicted herself in the past like 5 seconds, which is
why Andrew is making this face right now. Am I Am I I don't think
they're doing there's not like high level philosophy happening
here, but she also like kind of got herself there.
>> Like uh equation how you test >> I'm sorry. I'm
sorry. I don't mean to be as hesitant here. I just assume I know
the least about philosophy. So I'm trying to be humble and not
just be like you're even though it appears that way.
>> are so is a grippa trillemma a truth >> It's not
an axiom. It's a philosophical system and it's a philosophical
like uh equation how you test your own thinking. So how do you
>> and so I'm super confused. >> Give me a truth
claim that doesn't solve >> you don't have to make your
argument. >> This isn't my argument. My argument is all
arguments foundationally will fail a grippa dilemma. >> Okay.
So you are making an argument. You're saying that's not true.
>> I didn't say anything like that. I asked you how it
was true. >> Wait. So you're agreeing with me that no truth
claim. >> I didn't agree with anything. So you but you
have to those are the options. >> I don't have to do anything.
You're making an argument. >> I guess you could be a coward
and you could run away. >> It's not cowardice. You posit
that there's that grippa trima is true.
>> And I'm saying that's assumed because all things are
at a foundational level are assumed. And I said can you give
me an example?
>> But one of the legs of
this is a statement axiatic statements. This is a statement that
is taken to be true to serve as a starting point for further
reasoning and arguments. It is a statement that doesn't require
proof. It is self-explanatory. You like you have likely So, she's
literally leaning on one of the legs of a grippa's trilmma to
prove a a grippa trillemma is true. Can't make it up. Literally
can't be you can't make it up. Yeah. I assume this is saying
that at some point you have to give away like one of these things.
You have to stop doing these things to get through an argument.
I assume
that if unless the other person's willing and she's trying to
do something where she's like saying you have to be good faith
with me and allow me to make some assumptions. Okay. So, you
think >> assuming God exists is >> so when I ask
you does God exist and you say yes, that's not true. >> It's
true and I'm assuming it. >> How is it true? >> Uh,
it's true because I believe it's true.
I'm a divine command theorist. >> So, okay. So, I just
want to make sure I got this right. >> How do you He's
just going to run. >> When you when you posit Well, you
>> have to pay like 10 bucks to force this >> How
do you posit [laughter] the arguments and then I I have to answer
to the argument. So if I pose an argument and I give you the
justification for my argument and it seems like the way that
you're acting is that you think that that is incorrect then you
have to pose me a counter. So I said if I'm wrong Andrew you
can just prove me wrong like that. Find me a truth claim that
isn't fundamentally unjustifiable.
Go ahead. How do you find me one truth that doesn't fail at all?
>> Who posits a grippa's trilmma is true? Andrew or or
audit? a grippers trailemma uh isn't it? This is like this is
like >> you've already said it's true. The answer is Aerudite.
I somebody told me this went I swear somebody's
somebody's been telling me that
this went really well for Aerodite.
Maybe it did. Maybe in other places Utherifro's dilemma is true.
Is Uthifro's dilemma >> Okay. Again, you Why are you asking
me questions about your argument? Because what you're doing I
think you're I can't tell I can't tell if you genuinely don't
understand a grippa's trma maybe or if you're being bad faith.
Those are the >> How am I being bad faith when you pause
an argument and I ask you about it? >> Relax, Andrew. I
said there's two options. You genuinely don't understand or you're
being bad faith. Right. >> Well, there's a third option
which is maybe you don't understand. >> I do understand
how dilemas work in >> Okay, then let's >> are trolley
problems true. If a grippa's
>> is like a tri. >> Yeah, I'm just want to make
sure. Agria >> is a philosophical test of logic. >> Okay,
I got it. >> Well, the but the point of the trillemma is
that you cannot get through the trillemma, right? The point of
the trillemma is that like essentially one of those things can
be done for any argument. There is a there is a goal or there
is a thing with the trillemma sets up to ask is it possible to
prove any truth? Essentially according to the argument, no it
is impossible to prove the validity of any argument. This is
the claim it makes. So there's a
that is used to prove that no claim is truthful. You are saying
that no claim is truthful and positing that a group of trillemma
proves this right and saying do you have a something that disproves
this. I don't think he needs something that disproves it.
I again I think it's being used to talk about good faith in this
case. I think
>> so. When you're talking about agria's trilmma, would
you have a any criticisms for your for this argument that you're
>> So, okay, I think I'm getting this a little bit right.
Am I getting this a little bit?
So, I think there's another coralary of this, which is probably
going to be that a lot of the truths that you accept are probably
because of more of the maybe there's an extension of this that
more of the truths you accept are based on consensus than divine
command anyway.
Maybe maybe there's something there that's like a correlary.
>> Say that the
when I ask you is a grippa trima true. >> I can't solve
it. >> Is it true though? >> Is a trolley problem
true? Is Euthifro's dilemma true? What are we doing right >> Yeah.
I think I think philosophically you can you can say thatusion
is true or >> No. No. The agria's trilmma isn't a conclusion.
A grippa's trilmma is
I >> it is it is though. It is.
uh it seems to be ancient Rome's version of godal incompleteness
before developmental before development of formal symbolic logic.
Oh maybe yeah
could be >> it's a problem. It's a philosophical problem.
Is Uifro's dilemma true? >> Wait wait wait. I'm not talking
about I'm talking about a grippa's trma. >> Yeah it's a
problem in the same way that you uh dilemma is. >> Okay
so problem is true. >> Walk me through a grippa dile dilemma.
I'll make sure I understand it. >> Okay. Grippo's trilmma
posits that no beliefs are justifiable foundationally because
they will fail one of >> it can't be true. It's not it's
just it's not true or false.
But you actually believe the thing you just said it posits is
true. I'm I understand what she's saying. The trillemma is there
or something. And she's trying to flip it without asking the
question without putting in what it posits. I suppose >> three
ways dogmatism infinite regression or circularity. And I'm saying,
can you find me an example of a truth claim that doesn't fail
a grip? >> That sounds like that sounds to me like you're
positing propositions in a >> I'm giving you something
similar to like author dilemma or a trolley problem to see if
you can solve it logically. >> Yeah. Yeah. But that has
nothing to do with with a grippa trma which we're talking about.
So >> it has everything to do with trma because you're
asking if it's true which is like asking me if trolley problems.
>> No, it's not. >> Are trolley problems true? >> If
it's a if it's propositional, this sounds like propositional
logic to me. You're actually giving me premises and a conclusion.
Is the conclusion true? >> This is not what's [clears throat]
happening. It's a dilemma. Is the Euthifro dilemma true? >> Well,
that's a that's a whole different thing. I'm talking about >> a
onetoone comparison. This is the comparison I'm trying to make
cuz I feel like you're not understanding what a dilemma is. >> Write
it out for me.
>> I I don't need to. Do you Wait, how do you solve Ethro
dilemma or do you think >> right now? I just want it written
out so I can see if this is a non-propositional
>> Okay. I'm just going to write out what I've said. >> Okay.
It says so Munchous and Trillemma is also known as a Grippa's
trilmma. So I guess it's just a different name for it. Scroll
back up. >> Yes, I'll read this here. Keep working on this.
But the circular argument in which the proof of some proposition
presupposes the truth of that very proposition. The regressive
argument in which each proof requires a further proof at infinitum.
The dogmatic argument which rests on accepted precepts which
are merely asserted rather than defended. The trilmma then is
having to choose one of the three equally unsatisfying options.
Okay, >> hopefully you can read that. >> Sorry if
you can't. Just tell me if you need me to rewrite something.
>> Uh circular argument, infinite regression or dogmatism.
So then you believe in objective truth, right?
>> Uh I believe in objective morals. Yeah. And like uh
scientific realism. >> Are they objectively true? Uh
>> Well, objectively like they exist outside of me.
>> Is that true?
Okay. What makes it true? >> I'm assuming.
>> So, is everything you assume true? >> No. But
everything I assume is true because I'm really good at philosophy.
>> How do [snorts] you solve? All I'm >> has nothing
to do with me. >> It does. >> You can't you don't
believe. >> So, here's what's happening. How do you solve
Utherifro dilemma? >> Why does that Why do I need to solve
your problem? >> Because if I'm posing youthro's dilemma,
a philosophical problem, you can't go is the problem true. That's
not that's >> I'm not even asking about that. sidestepping
the conversation. If you if you believe that this is correct
and you also believe that objective morality is >> Yeah.
Correct. Correct in the way that we're assuming a grippus trilma.
Correct in the way that like trolley problems are good at testing.
>> So we're just both making assumptions about everything.
>> Everyone is well that or you're infinitely regressing.
Those are your two Well, there's your circular reasoning which
is just tautology. So everyone's kind of doing tautology. >> So
we're just assuming God. >> Yeah, of course. >> Okay.
How >> did she did? She She just got caught out. She just
got caught there and spun out when Andrew asked her if like everything
you think is true. She just like she just me'd out of that, right?
>> How are you not? >> So all these things all of
these things in philosophy are just going down to these three
categories for you. >> No, not these. These aren't categories.
These are ways in which you're facious. Your thinking is facious.
So it's saying all beliefs, all meta ethics, normative frameworks
are fundamentally unjustifiable because they can't solve for
one of these three things. Thank >> I see. It's probably
if it was a grippa who posed it's probably not saying that, right?
It's it's probably saying that it thinks all logical stuff is
like there's some there's some form of logic they would have
had back here, right? Like I think Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Definitely.
Um, if it's actually a Grippa who did it, who posed this at some
point, then I'm
I'm guessing it's not saying everything about every form of philosophy.
Might be true. It might just be fundamentally true. I'm trying
to look at God's theory of incompleteness.
>> and I'm asking you, how do you solve >> I can't.
I'm going to adopt it. >> He's like, you're supposed to
literally turn this. No, no, no. I'm going to adopt it. You're
right. I'm just going to turn I'm just going to assume it would
be like everything's >> it'd be in like the year 30 being
like the year not turn of the century turn of the
from BC to AD. >> True. Because I assume it >> that's
that's fine. But now >> that's what you said. >> Now
you're in line with like So this is one of your issues. >> That's
what you said. >> Yeah. Yeah. No, that's fine. Welcome
to my world. Okay. Yeah. I'm in your world. >> We're based
over here. Okay. The issue is that I wouldn't go to secular people
and be like you don't have a moral ethical system because it's
unjustifiable. because I already know that mine's unjustifiable.
I'm assuming I'm doing dogmatism and they're doing usually infinite
regression >> or they're being cowards and they're being
like I don't know. >> So then you can't make a justification
for why I shouldn't like pull out a machine gun and kill everybody.
>> This these are not the same thing you Yeah. So when
I'm talking about foundational beliefs
>> Pop quiz. What's foundational? Do you know what foundationalism
is? >> Yeah. The it's going to be the pillar in which a
belief stands on. >> Yeah. Okay. So not all statements
or >> Thanks for the pop. You're welcome. Well, I don't
actually do pop quizzes. I usually ask question, but go ahead.
>> It's not me knowing more information than you is not
like some some some crazy like maniacal tactic.
>> I I I feel like she built a lot of arguments for Andrew
around a Grippa's trillemma and he asked her to like basic he
basically Uno reversed it and she's kind of rattled at this point
is why is what it seems like.
Um, I don't think she's totally wrong in what she's saying. Like,
yes, it ultimately all is just what do you actually, you know,
there's some bias in what you think is aimatically true or something
in the world. And yeah, sure.
But I I do think the general argument it's like also
if you say a grippa's trilmma in a debate, then the debate is
pointless. If that's actually your answer in a debate in any
way, the whole debate is pointless, right? Like like the whole
point is you're arguing the things and you're trying to say this
is why I believe it. You're trying to convince the other person.
Like you're literally saying, "Well, nobody can prove a truth
claim." You You guys could say, "But she's not going to the next
point." If she said, "This is all in service of me saying to
you that we need to agree on where we'll actually be charitable
to the other person." If she could just say this instead of continuing
to continue to spiral on this, I think that's fine. Okay. Uh
maybe this is this is true. I I suppose that's um what I was
saying about consensus earlier. It might be. She's not I don't
think she's she's not justifying. Maybe that's just me. I want
like the justification for why we're doing this. >> When
we get to the point where you do, >> this is the issue,
Andrew, is it speaks to your insecurity that when I ask you questions
about whether or not you know something, I'm asking in genuine
good faith because they're like esoteric and I don't expect people
to know them, but you take it as an insult to like your pride
or something like that. Of course, because you think I'm doing
something like maniacal when it's like me asking you, "Do you
know what a grippers trilma is?" isn't to say, "Huh, idiot, you
don't know anything about a grippers trusty."
is for me to go, okay, if you don't, let me explain it to you
and then I'm curious how you would reason through >> Yeah.
I would just reason that I'll adopt it and anybody that I decide
to impose my will on can't actually say that I'm unjustified.
>> Of course, you can. >> Well, you wouldn't say
that your foundations are unjustified, but they would say, for
example, here's a list of evidences and arguments as to why I
don't think >> Yeah, but none of those are justified. They're
all >> built off of tautologies. >> So what? >> Everything's
built off of ta. >> There's no justification. Tell me I
can't do anything. Wait, do you think math doesn't exist? Because
>> what does that have to do with what we're talking about?
>> Math is tautological. >> Oh my god. >> Wait,
do you not know that? >> What is the just pop? Do you know
that >> How can you tell me? You see what I mean? Pop quiz.
[laughter] >> Well, I'm doing it now cuz you're just being
ridiculous. >> I I don't know why she's doing this. I don't
know, dude.
>> Squirrel brain. Can you tell me? >> I'm pretty
focused. Can you tell me tell me how it is then that you can
create any justifications that anybody's ever doing anything
wrong? >> Logic and reason. And you build on top of like
tautological axioms that seem reasonable based on kind of assumptions
but they seem reasonable and you build upon an entire structural
of world belief which is >> none of them are justified
>> at a foundational level. No, all beliefs are unjustifiable.
>> Well then you you don't >> how do you sell dogmatism?
when you just told me then that I can't >> like it's it's
basically like she showed up and she said show me that anything
like is this is this really different than showing up and saying
um actually we shouldn't even be debating this because we live
in a simulation and then going now prove we don't Yeah. It's
like I I I
need to dumb it down for myself cuz like when I think about it
in like an in this abstract way, I I need to dumb it down for
myself cuz I don't like keeping things in my brain that are abstract.
I like having concrete examples for things like abstractions
so that I can explain it to people. But I think that's essentially
like I don't know. It's you're you're asking something that's
unprovable, right? or you're you're pausing that basically all
of your discussion is unprovable because of some total like imperceptible
fault with humanity,
thereby nothing you say is is really true. Now, if you want to
say that and basically use that to argue that divine command
is not a justification for something, that's fine. But I do truly
believe that Andrew essentially says he's not going to argue
things based on divine command because he doesn't think that
he should convince other people that way. So, I don't know.
can't go to secular people and tell them that their beliefs are
unjustified.
>> You can't and be cohesive, be >> So then we should
just throw philosophy
>> why not? It's not justified >> uh at aational
level. >> But now, but now why are we Okay, so now somebody
explain to me how did we get here from where we were? How did
we get here from basically saying like justify to me why like
based on what you you'll impose on other people justify to me
why every third kid wouldn't be bad like justify that to me and
and the response was a grippus trillemma
and it's like okay
I this seemed to all be dodge saying yeah I basically agree with
consensus
which I think just has to be your opinion as a liberal anyway
so I don't I actually don't know that we make up because people
accept tautologies because that's how you think about the world,
right? Like math, we just accept tautologies in math. We have
to >> like I understand where she's coming from with this
that you have to allow for some joint set of axioms, some joint
set of like agreed upon knowledge because if you don't agree
upon this knowledge, you could technically always say there's
some agreed upon knowledge I disagree with that foundationally
undoes your argument.
And that's sort of how you use a Grippa's trillemma.
But
it's
but he doesn't argue that in debates even less. So you could
say but it it hits both of them equally because she also says
she's divine command
So I I don't even know.
I don't even know because you have no starting point if you don't.
So we assume these things and then we build on top of them. And
then the beauty of things like math and science in the case of
like um you know science realism is you can use math and these
things to observe and test and see if you're actually mapping
onto the correctness of the world. >> I see. So then if
I inductive and >> so then if I utilize the assumption
that God is real this >> that's dogmatism. Yeah. >> Yeah.
This would satisfy you because you also use the assumption that
God is >> I'll just grant it. Of course I always grant.
So then if that's if that's the case and we assume that God's
real and then we assume God's commands and then we build our
case off of that >> that that's justified as justified
as something can be.
>> Okay. Well then I don't know what we're arguing about.
We'll just do that. >> Well, we were arguing because you
wouldn't ask for Griffith's dilemma and saying that it wasn't
true and coping. >> No, I was asking you if it was true.
>> Well, we're arguing this because you were walking me
along this thing and being like secular people have no justification
for their worldview. And I went, "Well, we can go there." And
>> this is okay. Secular people have no justifications
for their worldview.
Nobody has a justification for the worldview.
I So I think that's essentially just Andrew's point.
Like I remember I always go back to his debate with Vos where
he's saying to Vos repeatedly, I don't care if you believe in
God. I'm not going to argue that my divine command theory belief
actually supersedes yours. All I'm going to argue is that my
div demand uh divine command theory belief actually is equal
to your preference.
So when you talk about liberalism, it's based on preference and
my divine command theory preference is equal to your preference.
I am an equal operator in this world. So I'm just going to ask
that you don't dismiss me because of my belief in divine command
theory, which is totally fair. Unless he's changed from that
foundational argument he's always had. I actually don't even
know.
Like, she's basically just used all of this to argue up to what
Andrew already believes.
>> Andrew, but I'm just gonna like jump ahead to a >> trial.
I still I still want to get back to the interrogation. >> Okay,
but your line of argument. >> Yes, it made him say it.
He always says it. He always says it. He said it with Vosch within
like 90
He always says this, even less.
We just did this whole thing to get to the thing Andrew would
openly admit if she just asked him.
You could just ask Andrew directly about this. He will say, "Yes,
this is what I believe." Oh, you're totally brain right >> Is
going to fall apart because when you go, "Well, why are you assuming
that this is good?" I'll go, "We're assuming >> Okay, that's
fine. But anyway, back [laughter] to Can we get Can we get back
to this now? >> Okay. So, when we're talking about the
issue of secularism
>> or not secularism, I'm sorry. Liberal >> Still
never answers your question.
You're you're so you're so brain broken. It's it's unfortunate.
>> Liberalism is what we're discussing
>> So, we'll pull back up on the note since we went down
that whole train of >> It's not nonsense. It's like foundational
philosophy. Phil 101. Really, it's kind of important. You like
to weaponize it for your dumb audience against mean people to
like innocent only fans girls to be like see their belief system
is justified and it's like no one's >> name a single time
when I've done that. >> Uh every time you were on the show.
>> Yeah. So give me you got do you have >> Uh yeah
when you debate any secular person when you debated Charlie when
you debate Destiny when you debated Nimo when you debated Zeno
when you debated like etc etc
your belief system's unjustifiable
that's a dire [clears throat] your belie
at the end. I just say if it's the case that it's just preferences
then you have absolutely no criticism for me imposing >> U
well most most >> that's Yeah. So, he literally just said
what he always says.
I don't I actually don't understand how you could so catastrophically
misread Andrew from every debate he has. The guy doesn't change
the script. He just wrote the script in a way that favors him.
He never changes the script.
How do you misunderstand his point?
Most secular people, if they're good on philosophy, wouldn't
say, well, it's not just preferences, right? It's it's some mixture
of like we use if they're utilitarian, they would use utiles.
>> Not really. These are like there's no more preferences
than you preferring >> That's my point.
>> But then but Erida, you agree with him. A group is trilmma.
A grippa trillemma.
A grippa trillemma. Everything is
You just you just proved it yourself. A group of trilmma >> and
all of this is empty. >> That's right. >> So your
arguments wait but then you have to grant that your arguments
are just as empty as theirs. >> If that's the case, then
you would have no room to criticize me for imposing my preferences.
Because then we could just use reason and logic and evidence
of what seems to benefit people. >> Your preferences versus
my preferences. >> I think it's reasonable to assume that
I prefer that what
she just
did this whole argument to prove what he already says. I
>> like people are well people experience less harm, right?
I think that's a reasonable preference to have cuz I want >> Then
it's perfectly reasonable for me to say no. I didn't say it's
unreasonable. >> Then there's nothing to argue >> because
you're insisting that they're unjustifiable while you are and
I'm saying no, you're all unjustifiable, but both are actually
reasonable. You can have your Christian preferences, but as a
Christian, I'm fighting you and saying actually your preferences
are icky and bad for the faith. Don't do it. Also, Jesus wasn't
political, so you're kind of going against what Jesus taught.
Also bad to do. >> Okay. So then back to this when we're
>> I I I
when did she come up with that cuz that is an argument that Jesus
wasn't political that probably anybody who's engaging in politics
is actually not Christian by default. Essentially by engaging
in politics you're engaging in something some like kind of power
grab some some
by being an influencer you are putting yourself up as an idol
of sorts. There's a ton of arguments around this, how a lot of
this stuff is not really
but then how do you explain anything she's done as somebody who
says she believes in divine command on her personal basis? She
literally ran a pack. She literally like was running progressive
victory at some point. Was she not? Was she not one of the top
people in Progressive Victory working towards a Biden win for
Biden shirts? I'm going to have to switch off of this pretty
soon. I >> This person's like just a massive rage baiter.
It's it's awful. It's awful to >> And the system of liberalism
and you're appealing to consensus, right? If the consensus is
that they want to every third baby, which is just part of their
like preferences, man, and they assume that it's fine. You don't
you can't actually critique that then. >> Of course you
can. We do it all.
>> Andrew's point here is now going to be so just for people
who can't update their mental models. Okay. Andrew's point here
now will be their their contention is Aerodite says I'm not justified
in enforcing my preferences, my morality on other people and
Andrew says I am justified. The the argument is between two people
who claim to hold the same personal morality and the argument
is over whether or not they can enforce that personal morality
on other people,
right? whether whether or not they could justify doing so >> all
the time >> with what >> um you could use util utilitarianism
and you could say actually babies is bad because it makes a worse
world it harms that specific baby it probably also harms the
mother which would actually decrease the amount of flourishing
and increase the amount of harm which is why I think it would
be bad to do that's what a utilitarian could say >> and
then say but you would say that that >> so again
so again
just real quick the argument there would be like let's say It's
not a scientific society. Like, let's say it's not a scientifically
advanced society. Or maybe maybe that's pointless, I guess. But
my whole thing was the the religious element of the sacrifice
of the kids, right? Do you think it's going to help with the
harvest or something? So, you do this ritualistically. You do
believe there's a utility there. You believe there's positive
util there. And so, utilitarianism can argue against it. And
then I don't know, I don't know how you argue against it from
another framework. If you think you're getting like positive
stuff out of it, you essentially need to build up like personal
liberty and you need to be familiar with those philosophers,
right? Like having personal having rights that are given out
to every person.
But I guess I'm trying to think what is this downstream of Christian
values in liberalism, sacrificing kids.
We'd have to go back. >> God doesn't like it when you kill
babies unless he orders you to do it like in >> And which
one of you is right? >> Well, we would have to fight. I
mean, the issue is like we have to assume at the end of >> fight,
right? >> Yeah. And I would go, I think my argument is
more reasonable. I wouldn't say my argument is more justifiable
at a foundational level. This is what you do. You try to say,
"My beliefs are foundationally justified and yours are not, which
is why I'm reasonable and you're not." It's like, that's not
true. >> Actually, I do the opposite. I start at the end
of the argument and say, "I agree with you. It's all >> pro."
Just because you the like chronology of how you get there is
different. It doesn't change that this is the tactic that you
typically utilize when you debate people. >> Listen, I'm
doing the same thing with you. We're at the end now. >> Yeah.
You're like, I start at the end and I walk people all the way
back to a I'm just asking >> and then I go see how silly
this is. I'm not silly and I'm saying you're justice
single question here which is that reason consensus when you're
talking about consensus
that that >> so that's Andrew's arguing are you going to
appeal to consensus
>> like I'm not appealing to consensus. I know my beliefs
aren't consensus. I argue to try to transform my beliefs into
consensus. Will you appeal to consensus right now and just agree
that if I can get the consensus on my side that I'm morally justified?
Christian nationalism is morally justified so long as we can
win electoral seats and take this country over
that we will do so via consensus otherwise he's basically got
her in a vice okay where she will have to undermine political
uh like political winds by Christian nationalists somebody like
JD Vance right she'll have to undermine the political system
as it exists in some way she'll have to undermine institutions
and say no I don't believe that even if you could take the system
over as Christian Christian nationalist I don't believe that
would be justified I I think that's broadly where they're trying
to go, both of them. >> That's how you want things to be.
>> So if she says she appeals to consensus, then Andrew
says, "Well, I'm trying to appeal to the consensus, too,
>> Well, no. This is not an a like a consensus isn't an
aught. I think it's the best system that's arrived so far. >> So
when I asked you a better one, >> when I asked you earlier,
>> so when he asked you if you rely on consensus, you just
this entire thing, she just conceded.
She just conceded.
She literally just conceded.
For anyone not paying attention,
this is aerodite right now.
Oh, dude.
[laughter] I I do believe she just conceded though.
so it's the best system we have, so I defer to it. What did she
concede? She refused to concede that she relies on consensus
to determine what's right and wrong right now. And she says,
"Well, I just think consensus is the best system for determining
what's best for society, what's right and wrong right now."
On a societal level, consensus.
So he's about to ask. So when I asked you if you defer to consensus,
you now agree that you defer to consensus. Yes. >> This
is an uh and you said yes. That's not the case. >> Uh well,
there's a second part to what I was saying, I believe, at the
time. >> No. I asked you is consensus how we ought do how
Christians ought to do things. You said yes. >> No, I didn't.
>> Yes, you did. >> I specifically wrote it down.
>> If I did, I didn't mean it. >> You didn't? >> No.
I should have clarified. What do you actually want to ask here?
>> Yeah. So, I want to just ask you about consensus. So,
>> now the weird thing is is she was refusing to do consensus
as like an ought before. So, I don't know when he wrote it down
cuz she just basically conceded that it's the best system. If
it's the best system, I assume you think you ought do it.
But if she just is she going to do this would be another way
a Gria's trillemma would come in, right?
to be fair if she wasn't doing the smile and stuff. if she wasn't
doing the weird I don't know the weird performativity. I It just
feels weird to me. But if she wasn't doing that, I don't think
there's something wrong with saying I misspoke. I didn't mean
that. But I thought she was denying consensus before. And then
she said consensus is the best system. See, you might think that
was her conceding. But if you considered that consensus can be
realized via divine command, not via universal divine command,
of course, but by her personal divine command, which can be can
then be extended universally based on reason and
>> to be fair, >> that's not far off from Andrew's
argument. Just so you know, Marty Epste actually if she went
down that line, it's actually not far from Andrew's argument.
Basically, he's saying, "I'm not going to use divine command
to convince other people. I'm going to I'm personally believe
in divine command, but I'm going to convince other people via
consensus." I think that's actually I think that's actually what
Andrew's belief is already, which is funny. >> Want to
every third baby.
>> I would oppose this. >> Yeah. But why would they
be actually wrong? Uh I would for example I would in the case
of a >> don't don't say on a personal basis society how
do you society argue >> pagan I would probably appeal to
their own moral system I think that most people for example I
believe you probably believe this too that God gives us conscious
right he like puts a spirit inside of us that um god's uh metaethical
system emerges naturally out of us right so like what I would
do for example is I would probably first of all try to examine
that pagan's belief system and I would be like do you actually
think babies is okay right I would I would I would actually morally
question them. And one of the issues is that this is unobservable.
We can't truly know whether somebody thinks something is wrong
or right. But I think the knowledge of wrong.
>> But but no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I I think we just
have like empirical evidence that this isn't the case. Like there
are societies where they do believe things like, well, sacrificing
to the gods actually puts the sacrifice thing in a place of honor
in the other world. Like it's actually not bad to do. There are
times when you do it. There are times where this happens, but
they're specific and they're set up in a way that like doesn't
destroy society obviously, right? So, why no ritualistic sacrifice
society ever has like we're going to actually kill everybody.
You don't just get to go to the other there's like rituals to
it. There's timing to it, but those sacrifices are
acceptable like because of you know, you're not hurting the person.
You're actually honoring them by doing it, right? And you're
gaining something from it. Now, none of that is true, but you
can't opt you can't argue with their moral system.
>> A right is really important. Kind >> doesn't work.
>> Biblical, one might even say. So, I would question whether
or not they know it's wrong or right. And then I would appeal
to things like state. So, like civic ei civic ethics, for example.
It >> Dude, I I won't do this cuz it's going to verge on
starking. And I'm not trying to I'm not trying to stark on aite,
okay? But just the mouth sounds here. The mouth sounds here are
a lot a lot a lot a lot. >> I would appeal to things like
state so like civic ethic civic ethics for example. It doesn't
work very well in nations to kill every third baby. You're just
reducing your population. Usually the mothers don't like it.
Usually the fathers don't like it. Doesn't seem to have any good
outcome. In fact, most the reasons why people in the past killed
babies was to satisfy some sun god. >> Now I will Yeah.
Okay. Now, I will say I just need you to know I'm putting that
on the table so you can judge me accurately. Okay, moving forward.
>> That's not an overly reasonable argument. It's probably
more reasonable to say we shouldn't kill babies. That seems more
reasonable. So, I could appeal to them within their own worldview
of secularism or their own worldview of paganism. >> Sure.
And they say, "F you, we don't
>> Are they in my state?
>> Uh, no.
>> They're in another country. >> Yeah. I'm just
asking why they're wrong. Why they're doing something wrong?
>> Why they're doing something wrong? >> Why is that
wrong? Yeah, >> cuz I think it's immoral to kill babies.
>> Because I think God doesn't like you to kill babies
unless he orders it. Like in the Malikite. >> Because he
assumed you assumed that. >> I assumed God. Yep. >> You
assumed it. And so they assumed >> Well, I'm assuming God.
Yeah. >> So they assume not God. >> And so they come
to you and say, "Well, you're just assuming this anyway."
>> And I would say, "So are you." >> And then they
would say, "Good. We're going to go back to killing babies."
And the problem with that is why? >> I'd say, "I'm going
to use my language and quill to convince you that you're wrong
and that there's a more compelling and better way to live. And
I'm going to appeal to the spirit that I think God puts into
all of us to try to pull out of you the fact that murder is actually
really bad. >> So if a Christian nationalist does that
within a liberal system >> Yeah. That's She's literally
arguing all of Andrew's points. I HOW DID HE DO IT? HOW DID HE
DO IT? HOW DID HE GET HER TO COME ON HERE AND just argue all
of her points for him? All of his points for for him. How did
How did he do it? How did he do it? That's literally what he
says he's doing. Yes, she's doing it in jest, bro.
Do you [laughter]
>> They're not doing anything wrong. >> Um, yeah.
So, you guys can try to compel people to Christianity, but my
issue isn't Christian. >> No, we can compel you to We can
compel ourselves to the will of the state. Why not? What's wrong
with that?
>> You just I mean, >> I don't know what you're saying
right now. If if Christians take over the entire state, rewrite
the entirety of the Constitution within your liberal >> They
can in the liberal framework, but as a Christian, I think that
they're being uncchristian by doing so. >> Yeah, but who
cares? You're just assuming it. >> U God cares. And I'm
assuming that we're all Christian. >> Yeah, but I assume
God doesn't care. >> Uh I I would question your Christian
>> Oh, why? I just assumed it. >> Scripture. Do you
think that like logic, reason, evidence, scripture doesn't exist
outside of like foundations? >> It doesn't matter. What
matters is what I assume. How would scripture not matter when
I'm talking to fellow >> because I just assume things?
>> Well, no. You don't just assume things. You're equivocating
again. So, what you mean? Because you're saying assuming at a
foundational. So, when I say assume, I mean at a foundational
axiomatic level. That is not the same thing. >> My aum
is that I'm always right >> about everything. Why can't
it be an >> Because it's not tautological.
>> I'm right because I'm right. That's a >> Yeah.
Now you're Now I can go I don't think that's justified and then
I would prove you wrong. >> Okay, but who cares? You you
just said nothing's justified.
>> I would say that's not justified. Uh a grippus trillemma.
Can you prove to me that a grilemma is wrong? You give me a statement
that that confounds a grippus >> Sorry. Are we just doing
like nihilism warp tour? Nobody should care. Nobody should care
about you granted me that even at Christianity you granted me
that your worldview is just as un uh like unimportant. So how
do you make people >> Because that makes my point actually
your hands off. You're like, "Ah, none of it matters. My system
is justified." >> If it is the case, now I at least understand
what you're saying. So great. If it's the case >> took
2 hours and 15 minutes, let them >> Yeah. If it's the case
that we're just
I I think Erid is uniquely capable of arguing the other person's
points for them, proving their worldview is like valid, saying
you agree with their worldview, and then still condescending
to them after you've done all of that. I think she's like the
only person capable of doing that. It's actually crazy to watch.
It's actually like a wild ride to watch. It's It's borderline
just assuming the world >> or to quote Chudlo Logic. What
would Chud Logic say? It's unbelievable, bro. It's unbelievable.
He always does that. >> At a foundational level and it's
an axiom. I'm right cuz I'm right. Now we have a tautology. Then
there's actually no good reason for me not to assume that I'm
just right about reforming liberalism after my own image. >> So
reason can be includes things like inductive and deductive logic.
This is the stuff that we build off of our axioms, right? can
>> well that's what we do that's what all philosophical
systems are that's what you do that's what I do >> well
that's an assumption >> this is crazy >> because
foundationally you're assuming it right >> oh yeah you're
right Andrew everything doesn't matter anything at all and in
fact everything that you say doesn't matter and none of your
systems are justified and it's all just arbitrary and silly then
that's what you're saying >> by your view yeah >> no
no you granted my view you said I'll grant you a grippers >> yeah
that would this is our view now baby you said you're joining
me you're in the agrius trma acceptance state. >> In fact,
then if that's the case, >> you're just as arbitrary and
just as stupid and we can't assume anything. >> So So if
that's the case, then >> we should talk about anything.
Why are we here? Let each other finish, please. >> So I
just want to know, >> well, you're in my world. How are
you solving that now? >> What would the argument What What
now is the argument for me to impose Christian >> Let me
ask that to you. What's your argument for it? >> Cuz I
want to. >> You're just assuming that I want to. Yeah,
but that you're just assuming >> that it's a tautology,
so I'm supposed to. That doesn't make it. >> Exactly. So
it's fine to do. >> So why are you saying that it's an
>> Wait a second. I'm assuming,
right? >> Yeah. So, why is it an ought statement? >> Because
I want it to be. Cuz I assume >> Okay. So, your your system
is wholly unjustifiable. There's no reason why Christians should
do it. They're just like moving on violence. >> And there's
no reason for Christians not to do it.
>> Uh I So, I believe in a I'm a foundationalist. So, I
believe in >> Yeah. But you assume your foundations can't
be justified. >> Everyone assumes foundations. You've already
granted me this. >> Then if that's the case, then who cares
what your foundation In philosophy we typically ground foundations
to some >> We don't do anything in philosophy. I don't know
what you do with philosophy >> okay Mr. Philosopher in
in uh any level of respected philosophy we assume >> which
respected philosophers are you are you uh are you referencing
>> Plato Socrates
uh what are some modern ones that I can think of? >> What
did Socrates Socrates assumed that you couldn't justify anything?
Well, no. What he Well, sort of. What we do is we grant assumptions
because we understand that at a foundational level, they're all
unjustified. >> All you did was destroy the possibility
for there to be objective morality. That's it. >> Nope.
Because I think God exists. >> Yeah. But you just assume
it. >> So, but non-Christians also assume that he doesn't
exist. >> Yeah. So, then
>> I
if they have an anti-oral realist position, you >> I would
use logic and reason to compel them as to why I'm correct. >> Okay.
Let's assume for a second I'm a moral anti-realist. Mhm. >> Use
logic and and reason to compel me when you tell me that your
whole worldview is just assumed.
>> Sorry, [laughter] you really love that assumed word.
Can you rephrase that in a way that's coherent? >> That
was coherent, but I'll do it again. >> Let's assume it
wasn't >> Let's assume. >> I'm a moral anti-realist.
Okay. >> Your moral foundations are assumed.
>> And not justified. >> And I would say, how do
you solve a grip >> No, no, no, no. You told me the moral
anti-realist that. >> Yeah. And then the anti-realist goes,
"Well, your opinions are just assumed, right?" And I go, "Yeah,
how do you solve a group of >> Why would they need to?
They're
>> So, even even >> you just destroyed the possibility
for objective morality every >> No, I didn't.
No. Even >> uh how do you get out of this hellhole of an
argument where you can't make any moves outside of this is my
preference?
You just try. It's just down to rhetoric. They're essentially
saying everything's rhetoric. So, we're just going to argue our
points and try to argue them and say why we believe them the
best we can,
right? And we'll we'll agree on some set of assumptions
right?
That's
that's where you go. You just say we're going to do the rhetoric
we we can, the best we can,
because you're saying everything is that
that like you're just trying to that there is no foundational
truth. So, you're just trying to argue things in a way that that
goes and and hits people's hearts. But I guess there's a there's
a second level. There's a meta level to this, which is I think
Erid is trying to argue that Andrew Wilson's Christian nationalism,
the Christian nationalism push he's doing, the beliefs he has
are harmful. Right? I would imagine that's the broad brush of
the argument is actually Andrew Wilson's worldview is harmful.
And so probably if you're just going to say that nothing is real
I don't know.
I don't know. It's it's like difficult. It all comes down to
>> Even subjectivists fail a group of tramma. They fail
by infinite
>> Okay. Again, who cares? >> You forgot about that
one, didn't you? >> That doesn't hurt my argument. >> Yes,
it does. I if I'm an anti-realist, a moral anti-realist, I say
there are no moral facts and I that is completely and totally
in line with the grippa trilma. >> Reban Rubin donated
$3. This debate has me wanting to find a tree lima to tie a rope
to. >> Okay, that's a good one. That's a good one. Ruben
Rubin, thank you very much. >> Uh so
a group of trilma would say, "How do you solve for infinite regression?"
>> Why would I need to? >> Because it's a fallacy.
>> So thinking is a fallacy. No, infinite regression is
a fallacy. >> Okay, but everything's going to reduce to
infinite to an infinite regress, >> So, what's comes before
thinking? >> Well, that's that would be transcendentals
would come before >> Okay, what comes before that? >> Well,
we would make the justification of God, right? >> So, you
>> Oh, I I don't know why Andrew is trying to argue. So,
no secular. >> What are you doing?
>> No, not me. >> You don't assume. >> I do
assume God. We were talking about moralize.
Andrew, respectfully, we should probably I don't think you're
ready for this conversation. I don't >> No, I'm having
a good time with this one. I just want to make sure that me,
the moral anti-realist,
>> right? That you are telling me that objective morality
is real, right? >> Mhm. And I would use reason and logic
and argumentation and I would build off of my foundational axioms
that a good faith moral anti-realist would just grant me. So
they'd be like, "Well, why do you believe God?" And I'm like,
"I just assume him." And they're like, "Okay, well, I can't really
contend with that. It's just un assumed." And then I build my
entire case for why I think morals are rejected because I think
God instilled them outside of us and that they are in every person.
And I say you can see this in the universal way.
>> Okay. But how do you do all of that and then also say
>> morals consistently emerge
of humankind moving towards greater and greater moral systems,
right? Free speech and respecting one another and treating everyone
kindly. And what you'll notice most importantly is not only are
those morals objective, but they're the Christian ones because
God is real. My god specifically is real. That's how I would
do that >> Okay. So are there moral facts? >> Yeah.
Yes. >> That and are they just assumed?
yeah, at a foundational level.
>> Okay. So then any moral facts that I assume at a foundational
level are equivalent to any moral facts you assume at a foundational
level? >> Nope. Not equivalent. I didn't say these are
all equivocal. >> What would make them different? >> My
my use of inductive and deductive logic is better. I use better
reason. I have more evidence for my claim.
>> Hang on. What does better mean here? >> Better
means like more coherent, more consistent. Like >> why
is that better? >> Uh because it seems to produce uh better
thinking. It seems to uh >> Yeah, that's a tautology. [snorts]
>> it's better cuz it's better. >> Yeah, tautologies.
Welcome to Welcome to >> Phil. So then I just want to make
>> Is she Why does she just say she's a
That's like It seems like she just doesn't want to say she's
a utilitarian.
I I feel like I'm just I'm totally understanding why she has
quote arerodite. God is a utilitarian, right? God is a utilitarian.
I think she's just a utilitarian. No, >> So So you're just
going to endlessly be in a case of infinite regress and >> Sweet
of you. I appreciate that. >> And then and then there's
no moral facts or just assume. >> Just let me pour my energy
drink at Brian respectfully and then we'll get back into you
really struggling with >> Oh, I'm having I'm having a struggle.
That's true. >> You are. This has been very difficult for
me. I agree. >> Everybody Everybody does this and I I hate
it. I'm like the person who I like have to force myself to do
this cuz like to ever have like a contentious conversation with
somebody with an audience present. You have to do this. It's
like a thing you have to do. You have to cons like condescend
to the other person. I don't know it like like women should argue
that you shouldn't do this cuz
automatic foundational on the internet. You're a condescending
woman. You sound worse.
I'm a man. You're a woman. You condescend to me. I condescend
back. I win by like net 50 points. You lose points. Okay. I gain
points for doing that. We both condescend to each other. You
lose. I think women should try to argue to get out of this framework
cuz everybody does it and it's like super annoying to me to do.
It's very goofy, but like women should argue not to do it, okay?
Because they lose automatically. You can't be a woman and be
condescending and win. Just doesn't >> I mean, hey, you've
at least accepted my the reality that your beliefs are just as
unjustified as everyone else that you mock, which is great. >> So,
might makes right.
>> Yeah, it does. Yes, it Why wouldn't it? >> Uh
because of things like coercive power versus legitimate authority.
>> Who cares about that? You're just assuming it. >> No.
So again, >> just at its foundation, whatever arguments
you have, >> like all of this around me just doesn't exist
because I'm assuming it. >> Wait, wait, wait. Material
things. >> Is philosophy material? >> Yeah, it can
be. >> Pragmatism is often >> how uh you you just
your argument is literally a woman versus a woman. Evil Johnny
Bravo,
>> you just lost.
>> Pragmatism often interested in like material effects.
>> That's not material. That's You're just saying what
it's >> I am so sorry. [gasps] Hold on.
>> Party foul. Uh, >> you were so sweet to remind
me and then I destroyed your tech. >> Did we get all the
tech out of the way? >> Uh, can we get paper towels? Yeah,
I just uh pass
the optics. The optics. The optics, bro. The optics are not good.
The optics are not good, man. It's It's not good.
It's not good. It looks like she's like rattled. She's like losing
it. He's doing the face.
It's rough, man. >> Kyla there.
Little spillage. It's okay. Here. No, no, no. It's all good.
We I'll I'll take care of it. You guys continue with the debate.
It's all good. Don't worry about it. I'll No, it's all good.
Uh, >> let's get on your stream deck first, though, so
it doesn't get any worse. >> Yeah. Yeah. Here, let me take
care of it, though. You guys can continue on with the conversation.
It's all good. It's all good. >> I'm so sorry about that.
>> It's okay.